foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story the message from the man
Doug Britain's most dangerous prisoner
insisting he's no threat on the eve of
the hearing which could free him
I hate foreign
model prisoner
we'll meet essential needs but nothing
more the government's new Asylum
accommodation as we hear the local
residents promising it will mean War
it's a crisis with no borders as we see
in Tunisia where thousands of migrants
face racism and poverty
High gpt4 do you have Consciousness as
an AI language model I do not possess
Consciousness I do not have
self-awareness emotions or subjective
experiences
stop the march to thinking machines the
call from Elon Musk and fellow
technologists who say AI poses real
risks to humanity
a Kingsville common Charles's first
state visit sees a warm welcome in
Germany
he was like a whirlwind force of nature
funny sharp wit
[Music]
and a drag queen of hearts the tributes
to Paul O'Grady after his Unexpected
death
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening one of
Britain's most notorious Prisoners has
told Sky News from jail that is no
danger to the public as he makes a bid
to finally walk free Charles Bronson has
served nearly 50 years in prison one of
the longest serving inmates ever known
in voice messages sent to our crime
correspondent from behind bars he claims
he now hates violence and is a model
prisoner here's Martin Bruns exclusive
report
[Applause]
Charles Bronson told the parole board
his days of violence were over there'd
be no more taking hostages in prison he
promised for a long time he'd been well
behaved after 48 years behind bars he
said he'd had more porridge than
Goldilocks and the Three Bears and he
was sick of it
in a message from jail he summed up his
frustration
into the public over Danger
of never bring a danger to the public
all our fable love him love the world
I'm not in filthy cherished or a rapist
were murdered
so we're more dangerous to ourseling
Bronson was jailed for armed robbery in
1974 because of his attacks on staff and
inmates he's been locked up almost
continuously ever since much of it in
isolation
a prison psychologist told the parole
board that inside jail Bronson posed a
moderate risk of violence but if he was
freed he'd be high risk another
psychologist called by him even she said
he should probably stay in jail for now
but with a gradual release into the
community
Bronson showed the parole board some of
his artworks his drawings sell well the
panel was told he could support himself
outside prison
other artists wanted to work with him
like rapper Ice t21 who campaigns
against youth knife crime I'm hoping to
record a song with him
um make some poetry I want him to get on
stage as he suggested with me I think it
would work because a lot of people would
listen to him
um because of early years Bronson told
the parole board he was now a man of
peace I want to go home I'm an artist
born again
and that's all I've done for the last 10
years City Marcel a model prisoner
polite respectful
and they still won't let me there
no one is expecting Bronson's immediate
release or even a move to an open jail
he hopes the parole board will at least
advise a loosening of his strict prison
regime
thank you
and Martin joins us live Martin the
message from Charles Bronson clearing
his words to you but what message is he
likely to get then from the parole board
tomorrow
I'm pretty sure it's going to be bad
news for him and his lawyers I mean even
Charles Bronson can't be expecting the
parole board to give him immediate
release I mean imagine what that would
be like for a man who spent nearly half
a century in prison it would be very
very difficult for him to suddenly
be thrown out onto onto the streets I
think the best thing he can hope for is
that the parole board makes it clear
that it feels that a gradual lowering of
the security regime in which he's been
held for so many years is put in place
the problem that the prison service and
the parole board faces between them I
think is that he's never really been
tested outside of very very strict
regime he hardly sees anybody on a
day-to-day basis he's allowed out of his
cell for a maximum of 90 minutes each
day so you know almost 23 hours locked
up almost in isolation so he needs to be
tested and gradually introduced to
associate with more people so a
relaxation gradually of that strict
regime is something I think the parole
board might suggest is what's wanted I'm
sure it won't release him I'm sure it
won't even move him straight to an open
prison
the government's decision to hold
thousands of Asylum seekers in disused
Ministry military bases Means War One
local resident told us today sites in
Lincolnshire Essex Yorkshire and East
Sussex have been identified and a
minister told MPS that the facilities
would meet essential living needs only
it comes as part of a wider Crackdown
and a bid to deter migrants from
crossing the channel in small boats
Skies people and politics correspondent
Nick Martin reports now from
Lincolnshire
this is one of several former military
bases that the government says it wants
to use to house thousands of Asylum
seekers in order to save Millions on
expensive hotels just in front of that I
believe is where they're going to be put
in the modular units yeah it's going to
be there so I'll be able to see him at
my kitchen window and Sarah Carter lives
just a few meters from this proposed
site we know that not everybody that's
an asylum Seeker is is bad but you know
there's a percentage that are going to
be and they're going to bring that to us
she watched as immigration Minister
Robert generic said this new policy was
in the public interest accommodation for
migrants should meet their essential
living needs and nothing more
because we cannot risk becoming a magnet
for the millions of people who are
displaced and seeking better economic
prospects
what does today mean for you because it
looks like this plan is going ahead uh
it means war
it means we're going to we're starting
our fight with the home office
that's what it means
the government says four sites in total
will be used to hold around 6 000
migrants including this former prison in
Essex this video filmed just a few
months ago shows just how much work is
needed to make sites like this one ready
for people to live in it's understood
here at Raf scampton and Lincolnshire
that migrants will be housed in
temporary accommodation yet to be built
we're actually in the middle of nowhere
here it looks like a town but it's
actually not at an Airfield and these
are the living quarters for all the crew
and their families and just beyond this
fence Beyond these big hangers is where
the Asylum Seekers are going to be
housed 1500 of them
just right alongside all of these
families who are not happy about it
there's only one shop here and a closed
down Barbers and it's a three-mile walk
to the nearest town and residents as
you'd expect are pretty unhappy about
the idea of thousands of people moving
next door the government
they're the backlog they need
so if they're allowed to stay they can
enter the community they can start with
earning a wage and become part of our
society sticking in the modern Airfield
in the middle of nowhere is is not going
to help anyone no one asked you about
your views about this in the last few
weeks no one asked you what you think
about this plan no one's written to you
no no no one's phoned you up and says
look we've got this idea what do you
think nope we heard it all secondhand we
heard it all online like everyone else
did and that's how the council found out
too that the government's tough talk on
migration comes just a few weeks before
the local elections the government wants
this to be seen as a No-Frills no spills
approach to housing migrants Nick Martin
Sky News Lincolnshire
well many of the migrants to be
eventually housed in bases like RAF
scampton are currently trying to make
their way either across or into Europe
in the first two months of this year
5622 migrants attempted to enter the UK
via the English Channel illegally that's
more than 80 percent higher than the
same period last year it counts as a
fifth of all illegal border crossings
across Europe more than 28 100 in total
in January and February almost double
the number crossing the channel have
made the deadly trip towards Italy
across the Mediterranean that's up 118
on the same period last year where many
of them cross from Tunisia where the
government has cracked down on illegal
migration and the country's president
has been accused of stoking racism our
Africa correspondent user al-bahier
reports now from the capital Tunes
this is their new normal camped out
under the shadow of the offices for the
International Organization for migration
living in a constant state of appeal
a Crackdown spurred on by comments from
tunisia's president targeting
sub-Saharan African migrants has left
many of them homeless and jobless
and desperate to leave
how pregnant are you Fanta I'm seven
month friends not now okay how are you
feeling
um thank God I'm okay yeah
when are you expected to give birth
into in 10 weeks time 10 weeks time yes
all I need now is evacuation I want to
leave this country because I'm not
feeling safe in this country I don't
want my wife to give birth in this place
and just down the road another camp
this is a sitting in front of the unhcr
offices here in Tunis the people here
are Asylum Seekers they have the ID
cards that make them eligible for all
the protections refugees should have
here under the Geneva Convention but
they're not getting anything and they're
saying that the spike in hate crime has
them wanting to leave as soon as
possible
since the president's decree the racism
is just too much she says they called me
filth I was so upset
tunisia's foreign minister insists their
measures in place to protect sub-Saharan
African migrants in the country how are
they being protected sir what's what's
in place to protect them I think at all
levels I mean um at all levels again the
our authorities uh even for those who
have been who could have been I mean
harmed or anything or threatened uh this
can happen in every country I mean we
were as Authority we were not
responsible for what what person was
doing I mean you know that many
individuals could have take this
opportunity in order to to to to to to
you know to to act badly this can happen
everywhere
there's currently no National Asylum law
in Tunisia thousands of undocumented
migrants have been arrested in recent
weeks these two brothers from Nigeria
have just been released from prison
everything they took it I let this song
behind me witness I've not seen such a
thing I've never experienced such a
thing in my life how is it like for you
in prison it was hell because they were
not taking care of us nothing nothing
just punishing us acting like we are
slaves or whatever I don't know how are
they punishing you
because they were just treating us
anyhow like we blacks they were not even
caring for us
foreign
despite the division a sense of
community prevails but some damage
cannot be undone
the only appeal left now is one to God
prayer for a final place of Refuge
Sky News Tunis
there should be a six-month pause in the
development of artificial intelligence
systems a group of the world's most
prominent technologists including Elon
Musk said today that concern is over
what they called human competitive
intelligence which could pose profound
risks to society and Humanity whether
such a system could be conscious is a
question that's been asked by Geniuses
like Alan Turing one AI program though
today told us Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark that it's not
Lucy Edwards lost her sight at 17. what
page is a recipe for soup question mark
now she's helping to test an app running
arguably the most powerful AI ever
developed question gpt4 can understand
human words and pictures
so this is why it's incredible because
now I've got all of these kukri books at
my disposal so the potential you think
life-changing for Lucy AI is clearly
making the world a better place
so why now has a six-month pause on
developing even more powerful AI being
called for by the likes of Elon Musk and
over a thousand other experts they're
worried about things like misinformation
take fake images of Donald Trump being
arrested by police an event that never
happened but made almost Real by an
image generating AI
then there's AI is developing a mind of
their own gpt4 can pass exams but also
psychological tests of human
consciousness as we train those models
to be better and better at mocking
simulating human language they
spontaneously develop those very
Advanced very sophisticated properties
wait a year two three those models
they'll be so much better than us that
it probably will be very difficult for
us to comprehend even what you know what
those decisions mean
so what does gpt4 think it thinks
high gpt4 do you have Consciousness as
an AI language model I do not possess
Consciousness I do not have
self-awareness emotions or subjective
experiences my responses are based on
patterns found in the text Data I was
trained on
well that's a relief or is it an ai's
ability to even appear like it has
Consciousness is still a major
development if you expected so soon one
of the things that I think has really
struck me is the cycle of development to
release seems very very quick
in machine learning and AI it feels like
we're all subjects in some large
uncontrolled experiment
a lot of good might come out of this but
a lot of unintended consequences might
come out of this too
there's hardly a better example of trust
in technology than someone relying on it
to see but the speed at which AI is
growing is transcending our ability to
understand it let alone decide how best
to prepare for the consequences Tom
Clark Sky News I didn't a children's
mental health hospital is too close
after an investigation by Sky News and
the independent which revealed
allegations of systematic abuse the
alleged failings at taplo Manor in
Berkshire then run by the huntercom
group put young people at risk according
to former workers whiskey Sagittarius in
Berkshire for us tonight and said yeah
what are the hospital's owners had to
say then about this closure
well the hospital is now owned by the
Active Care Group which said it was a
difficult decision to make taplo Manor
is the third Children's Hospital
owned by the former Hunter Combe group
to be shut down here it is behind me in
Berkshire it has 59 beds and provides
specialist Mental Health Services to
children and young people now last week
the nhs's safety Watchdog the Care
Quality commission threatened the
hospital with closure following a
damning report and saying improvements
needed to be made but today the Active
Care Group said that it had taken the
decision to close the hospital it said
that the NHS is no longer making
referrals here making Services
unturnable it said that the patient's
most at risk were likely to be impacted
but it also blamed what it called
disproportionate media coverage and
media attention over the last few years
now Sky news's investigation with The
Independent Newspaper spoke to more than
50 patients who made allegations of
systemic abuse pieces have a listen to
what the parent of one of those patients
told Sky News tonight
what I know that my daughter Amber
really wanted to to see how to happen
was change she knows what happened to
her she knows that she cut changed the
past we can't do anything about it but I
know that she was one of many who just
adamantly do not want to see any more
young people suffer
well tonight the Active Care Group said
it's working to safely move patients
from here by the end of May
the White House tried to put pressure
tonight on President Biden's political
opponents to pass tougher gun control
laws in the aftermath of the school
shootings in Nashville Tennessee schools
and churches had become deadly places
for many Americans the president
spokeswoman said today people in
Nashville are continuing to mourn these
six people three of them children killed
on Monday our U.S correspondent Martha
Kelner reports from there
Covenant Christian School is obscured
from view Atop A Winding Road
parents pay to send their children here
partly because of the privacy and
security on Monday that facade was
suddenly and violently shattered
CCTV shows pupils running across a road
to escape an active shooter actor
Melissa Joan Hart whose children attend
the school next door was there
so we hopped on these tiny little little
kids across the road and get their
teachers over there and we helped a mom
reunite with her children and
um
I just I don't know what to say anymore
it is just enough is enough
this is one of Nashville's most affluent
suburbs where some of the victims
families live it is proof that nowhere
is safe from America's gun violence
epidemic
Covenant School teacher Cindy Peak was
close friends with Tennessee's Governor
she was supposed to have dinner at his
house on the day she was shot dead
but Republican Governor Bill Lee has
been steadily loosening restrictions on
gun ownership he wants guns to be more
readily available here in Tennessee
that is unlikely to change even in the
wake of this shooting
many here prefer to focus on school
security and mental health
I mean people this year have small
people down with cars and parades if
people want to do harm they'll do it but
I think that the fact that people think
to do harm
is a much more mental health issue I
think
the argument doesn't hold much stock
with Vidya whose son goes to school
nearby
a mentally unhealthy person can only do
so much with a stick or with a rock or
with a knife
a mentally unstable person with seven
assault rifles
can get into a locked door can get past
security can shoot police who are trying
to protect the community
they pray here knowing that this place
will never feel the same a sanctuary
shattered in a way that is so
depressingly familiar Martha Kellner Sky
News Nashville
Pope Francis is in hospital tonight with
a lung infection the Vatican says he's
been suffering breathing difficulties
following an infection and will remain
in hospital for several days the pope
appeared well during his regular General
audience today that he grimaced while
getting out of the Pope mobile
conservative MP Julian Knight has been
cleared by police of a serious sexual
assault the MP said the allegation was a
single false and malicious claim and
that his suspension and public naming by
his party had met his reputation was
dragged through the mud
the Prime Minister LED tributes to the
House of Commons only female speaker
baroness Betty boothroid as she was laid
to rest earlier today Rishi sunak was
joined at her funeral by many well-known
faces from Politics the former labor MP
who was elected to serve West Bromwich
in 1973 died last month at the age of
93.
now the bond between the UK and Germany
will grow ever stronger King Charles
told his hosts tonight on his first date
visit as Monarch he had been due to
visit France first but that plan was
postponed because of the violent
protests against President macron a
royal correspondent Laura bondoc has
this report
as greetings go this is as big as it
gets in Germany the Brandenburg gate
where East and West were once divided
now a monument to Unity and a moment to
rekindle International friendships the
king and the German president shoulder
to shoulder
no other head of state has been given a
ceremonial welcome here the highest of
honors for the King's first state visit
and a moment to remember for berliners
that the first country is Germany it's
an obvious sign because of the really
good bond between these countries before
the coronation which shows the good
relationship between the two countries
which I really appreciate this visit is
all about rebuilding relations after
years of brexit turbulence a royal
deployment of sensitive diplomacy
although this trip was supposed to start
in France there is a poignant symmetry
with Germany being the King's first
state visit it's here in Berlin where
the queen started her last back in 2015.
[Music]
he was famed for her Ballroom diplomacy
echoed here at the Bellevue palace with
the king and queen consort guests of
honor at estate banquet the relationship
between
Germany and the United Kingdom matters
greatly to me too Mr President
but behind the pleasantries from the
president a much blunter message
to melts today is the 29th of March on
this very day six years ago the British
government submitted its application to
leave the European Union I'll say it
quite frankly for me personally this was
a sad day
this is the soft power of the monarchy
in full motion and with war in Europe a
chance to strengthen ever important
alliances Laura bundock Sky News in
Berlin
the queen consort was also among those
today to pay tribute to Paul O'Grady the
star of television and radio who died
unexpectedly last night Palace sources
said Camilla celebrated the warm heart
and infectious humor of the man who made
his name as a very different Queen of
the drag variety as Lily Savage our arts
and entertainment correspondent Katie
Spencer reports
brought drag from the fringes of society
to prime time TV dear Lily can you help
me I don't know what to say when I meet
a woman a staple of Saturday nights in
the 90s
don't say anything to speak when he's
spoken to
his brassy chain-smoking blonde inspired
by the women who'd raised him growing up
in birkenhead he was like a whirlwind
force of nature funny sharp wit and he
never lost his working class Roots but
my Lord what a joy was to have around
his infiltration and acceptance on
mainstream TV made him a television
Trailblazer I'm not some cheap tire to
the Vauxhall Tavern you know the ACT
born from a time when the queer
Community had endured horrific
homophobia
this was where Lily started out an
eight-year London residency in the 80s
when being loud and Scrappy was a
necessity the AIDS epidemic saw National
newspapers stoking fears of a gay plague
and a Grady infamously was on stage when
the police raided wearing plastic gloves
so they didn't have to touch anyone that
they were arresting he joked they were
there to do the washing up got put into
into police cell and you know the whole
story then like came out but it sort of
resonated with them and on his last
visit here he said to me we really need
to get this apology in terms from the
Metropolitan please oh Godly here he is
a champion of the underdog particularly
if they were canine his award-winning
series for the love of dogs shining a
light on Animal Welfare
and attracting a royal audience with
Queen Elizabeth and the queen consort
y dogs and cats home Beyond thankful he
helped us raise funds he helped support
our campaigns he helped change the law
for animals in this country as well
academic celebrity never went to his
head in fact he'd quit his successful
daytime Chat Show because he said famous
people were so dull they were like
relatives he felt obliged to visit
you've made a heaven for who right where
and what for me right here when asked
how he'd like to be remembered he said I
don't care because I won't be here a
Trailblazer and a National Treasure Paul
O'Grady took no prisoners his warmth and
wit a rare gift Katie Spencer Sky News
remembering Paula Grady who died
yesterday
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this on the front of the
express which says fears of a Revolt
have halted government plans to raise
the state pension age well tonight we're
joined by the daily mirrors associate
editor Kevin McGuire and the Daily Mail
columnist Sarah Vine back in just a
moment
foreign
[Music]